Alhamdulillah.
Continuing in.
Yesterday we started discussing the
conditions of woodoo.
for
[Silence]
The author here mentions a third
condition of
and again he placed this in the
conditions
and
the difference between a condition
and a pillar
is that a condition is a prerequisite.
It's outside
of the act of worship.
Whereas a pillar or an obligation
is part of the actual makeup of the act
of worship.
If we understand that,
we understand that the only one of these
that's truly a condition is the
intention.
Is the intention because that's the
prerequisite. Correct?
Whereas
even saying is part of the actual
or which is succession.
Succession means that a person makes the
wudoo
each part in succession of the next
altogether.
Meaning a person can't make you know
wash the hands, wash the face at the
beginning of the day, wash the arms an
hour later, wash wipe the head an hour
later, wash the feet an hour later and
then have a full woo. No, it has to be
successively performed. Meaning that a
person makes the wudoo altogether.
The scholars say
that succession, the least of it is that
the first part of wudoo, the first
the first limb or the first place where
a person washes. So that would be the
face
doesn't naturally dry by the time the
person finishes washing the last part.
Right. So, a person washes his face,
then the arms, and then wipes the head,
and then somebody walks in that they
know, and they take a break or they take
a second to speak to them, right? As
long as their face has not naturally
dried
in a natural environment,
then they would just continue their woo
where they left off. But if there's such
a break between them
that the first pillar,
the first thing that you washed, which
is this case the face, the hands have
dried naturally before the person gets
to the end of the wool, then the woo
needs to be restarted. Needs to be
started over again, right? However,
anything within that is fine. How much
would we say that that would roughly be?
roughly how long would it take for
a person's face to dry
naturally
in a natural environment on its own?
Probably 5 minutes,
maybe four, something that. Right?
That is a general reasonable amount of
time
that the person has to make wuboo. If
the person doesn't make the final pillar
of wudoo, by the time the first pillar
has is still wet naturally,
then the wudoo has to be restarted. This
is what the scholars mean when they say
means that a person
make the wudoo successively meaning each
one right after the other until they
complete the wudoo because again wudoo
is a full unit right it's a full unit
kind of salah salah is a full unit
we can't make half and have it count
right we can't make
four or five laps around the cabba and
have them count. It comes in units,
right? You have to have fulfilled a full
unit. Seven rounds around the cabba to
count as
at least two to be counted as a one
in case of wub.
Now we're going to move into the
obligations of Udubul. What are the
obligations of Udul? The author
mentions the obligations of Udul
as being six.
And notice how he didn't call them
pillars of Udul.
Why?
Why didn't he call them pillars? We we
always say there is every act of worship
has conditions
and it has pillars.
In the case of woo
the scholars most usually refer to it as
conditions and obligations
not pillars.
This is one of the only acts of worship
in all of the legislation of Islam
where they do not cite these things as
being pillars. Rather, they cite them as
being obligations. Does anybody want to
take a crack at that and tell us why
they think that is?
Do we understand the question?
Let's look at the
definition of a condition, the
definition of a pillar, the definition
of an obligation. Okay,
a pillar and a and an and a condition
are the same thing
essentially.
The only difference between a pillar and
a condition
is that a condition
is outside of the actual act of worship.
It's not part of the actual makeup.
And a pillar
is part of the actual act of worship.
Right? You could imagine with me for
instance
let's say
let's say I'm building
a building
okay a bridge a big bridge
and I need to import steel from another
country to build this bridge right
so the steel itself that I'm importing
is a pillar
because that's part of the actual
bridge.
The licenses I need to build the bridge
legally
and the connections I need to have to
import that steel legally. Those are
conditions. Those are prerequisites.
My license isn't actually a part of the
bridge. However, that bridge will not
come to pass without me having that. Do
you understand? It's clear, right? So a
condition is outside of the act of
worship. It's not a part of it. We look
at something salah. We say for
instance covering the is part is a
condition of salah. a condition of salah
because me physically covering my is not
part of the makeup of salah but it's a
prerequisite
to the salah it's a condition for the
salah to be accepted
right
when we look at the time of salah
one of the conditions of salah is the
time has to be in it has to be the right
time for the salah. Not before its time,
not after its time. The actual time of
day is not part of the makeup of salah,
right? It's part of the context in which
the salah takes place. It has to take
place in this particular time otherwise
will not be valid. This is a condition
of salah. Whereas
is a pillar of salah. Sujud is a pillar
of salah.
Recitation of surah fat is a pillar of
salah. Do we understand the difference?
Okay. Now what is a
a
an obligation?
An obligation
is similar to a pillar but it's
different.
It's different in the sense that if a
person leaves off an obligation,
forgetfully,
then the prayer is still valid.
But if they leave it off on purpose, the
prayer is invalid.
A pillar, it's not that. a pillar.
If you forget it or if you leave it out
on purpose, the prayer is invalid. You
have you it has to be made up.
Whereas
a an obligation
is less is more lenient. If a person
forgets it, then the prayer is still
valid. But if a person purposely leaves
it off, then the prayer is what?
invalid. A good example of this
is the first
of a prayer that has two in it. Let's
say
a person forgets the first
they stand straight up from the second
into the third. They forgot.
Do they need to go back and make that
again? No. Prayer is still valid.
They may make suj
but the prayer is still valid. Whereas a
pillar
it doesn't matter if it was forgetfully
or knowingly the prayer is invalid. If a
person were to purposely
not
make the first they say you know what
I'm strapped for time. I don't have a
lot of time. I'm going to just leave off
the first the salah is invalid. The
whole salah it's invalid.
Why? Because they left off an obligation
on purpose
intentionally.
And the difference between a pillar and
an obligation is that a pillar has to be
made and if it is left out forgetfully
or purposely
the the prayer can't be valid without
it. Whereas
the obligation
there's room for forgetfulness. Do we
understand? So it's an obligation but
it's less serious,
right? It's less serious.
Now if we go back to the case of wudoo
and we say
every act of worship has conditions and
pillars. Woo. The scholars mention
conditions and obligations. They don't
mention pillars. Why? Why this
categorization? Categorization matters.
Go to the
greatest most knowledgeable muti on the
face of the earth
and ask him any question.
When he answers your question, where
will he be drawing from?
These technicalities, this is where he's
drawing from. When you come and you ask
him, I forgot this in my salah. What's
the ruling on this salah? What do I do?
He is going down a checklist that he
learned probably 50, 60, 70 years ago
before
you and I were even born.
And he is, you know, obviously it's very
quick. This is what he does. But this is
oversimplification. But what he is doing
is he is reviewing knowledge in this
way.
He is going down the checklist.
That is how a fetwa is formulated.
He doesn't make it up as he goes. These
are answers that he found
decades and decades earlier. So when you
say
and so this categorization matters. It
matters so much
because based on how you categorize
these rulings is going to
determine how these rulings are going to
play out their implications.
We will continue this tomorrow inshallah
[Arabic recitation]